forget the current crop the lackluster
Democrats running the person leading the
latest New Hampshire Paul isn't even on
the ballot that survey suggests that if
Michelle Obama were to enter the race
she'd be the front-runner
she's walloping the competition with 26%
support but before my first lady has
repeatedly resisted the flood of calls
to get in so what does that say about
the 20/20 field Dana that they're gonna
have to fight it out amongst themselves
and try to win on the merits Michelle
Obama is never running for office period
but there was this other story that came
out today it said that Mike Bloomberg is
thinking about getting back in the race
because remember he said he would not
get in the race if Joe Biden was going
to run now he apparently might be
thinking that Joe Biden is in freefall
so maybe he's gonna get back in the race
well I also heard that's not true what
do you think what does that tell you
about Joe that all these other you know
high-profile Democratic candidates are
kind of waiting in the wings we heard
Hillary last week people were talking
about her yeah what does that Cydia I
don't think it's as much about the fact
I read somewhere that people were
talking about whether Obama President
Obama could run again and what is the
law what is it and I thought this is not
to make to me this says nothing about
the field as dana says she's not running
she's a cultural figure Jesse I mean
she's not Beyonce
but she's getting close right yeah
because as I said I well I can repeat or
something I said earlier which is she
can she went on her book tour and she
filled arenas they were sold-out arenas
it's that sound like know he wishes he
wishes God said why he can make people
in see but I think you know the larger
issue is that people are still coming to
some conclusion you see this in the
polls not just in New Hampshire but
nationally that people will ship between
us my first choice my second choice I'm
not sure the big beneficiary so far is
Elizabeth Warren who's been taking
support away from Peabody to Kamala
Harris and Bernie Sanders well I still
think it speaks to the weakness of Joe
Biden yes in your heart and I think it
speaks to the weakness of Democrats in
general here's why because it's the
grass is greener on the other side and
we saw this in 2016 when they were pine
after Joe Biden because they felt that
he at that time better represented the
Obama era he wasn't getting beat up in
the primary or war and two they were
exactly and so I think it's just no
matter what cycle it is they're always
going to be pining for whoever's not
there you know their wishful for
Michelle I call that Miss full thinking
I can't remember what I said because I
almost had nothing to say because right
we've all said this is that there's a
terminal lack of excitement about the
big names meanwhile the most genuine
people you're not hearing about marry to
me marianne williamson is the most
genuine person up there but she's even
find i think yang yang lost his bang
she's the real thing the question is
will they go up dang if they go after
Joe I think it might be might at this
point if you like picking on Gramps you
think yeah I think they just might they
might just let him wander off into the
sunshine me why I'm gonna be brave
enough tonight I don't know maybe you
know maybe a hunter could run so the big
debate tonight obviously they're gonna
be asking about hunter and they're gonna
be making the Bernese attack against Liz
Warren for supporting capitalism how do
you see things shaking out yeah so
Bernie says he is gonna take her on
right he wants to say he's I am NOT a
capitalist and they're gonna have a big
fight about capitalism that would be
really great for the Democrats in the
general election here's one thing I
would say about Biden though if he were
to be able to get through this primary
process and become the nominee it's much
better to have had to deal with the
hunter situation in the primary than in
the general election because then by
then it'll be baked into the cake well
done at the end of the day unpack it
guys are full of analogies over here
you're full of it okay let's put it down